this is basically a fileted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now skinned off pick up your knife a
really nice broad flexible fill it a
knife little sharpen lift up the base of
the tail and then just Nick a little bit
at the Ender twist the knife almost as
if it's horizontally underneath the
salmon pull the skin and you slice the
salmon underneath and let the knife do
the work now get your skin flip it back
over and check your not leaving too much
salmon on top of the skin pull it back
nice and slowly get the skin wrap around
your fingers pull the salmon towards you
and then just all the way through lay
that down one nicely skinned salmon just
like a perfect snake skin get your knife
and just run the knife down and then the
pair of tweezers these are fish tweezers
but you can use normal tweezers look for
the head up and pull and with a skin
being removed from underneath the salmon
the pin bones come out a lot easier the
pin bones only go to just basically
halfway along the Filat one nice fill it
of salmon beautiful nice long strokes so
we get the whole of the blade three
fingers one in front two behind and this
part of the knuckle